- Encore une dizaine de jours,
après il ne sera plus
obligatoire. Presque deux ans
plus tard, la santé publique va
annoncer demain la fin du port
du masque dans les lieux
publics.
- Aller chez la coiffeuse,
j'aimerais qu'on porte puorte pu
de masque!
- Dans des foules compactes,
je vais le garder sans doute.
- La pharmacie, l'épicerie,
les autobus, c'est sûr!
- Je vais le garder, moi j'ai
jamais eu aucun problème avec
ça.
- Le port du masque va toutefois
demeurer obligatoire dans
les transports en commun et dans
les établissements de santé.
ELYSE BERGER PELLETIER,
urgentologue, Hôtel-Dieu, Lévis
- Pour l'hôpital, à mon humble
avis, on va le porter encore
longtemps.
tients COVID demeurent
nombreux dans les hôpitaux.
Le virus a changé les moeurs.
- On veut se protéger. Comme je
vous disais ; gastroentérite,
influenza, covid. On a
tellement de virus ces temps-ci
aux urgences qu'on va continuer
à le porter. On en discutait
entre collègues puis on sedisai,
on porterait toujours le masque,
je pense, en travaillant.
- En Chaudière-Appalaches,
95 personnes infectées
à la COVID sont hospitalisées.
La courbe est à la baisse.
Mais dans la Capitale-Nationale,
Il y a 232 patients COVID.
Un plateau semble atteint.
Dr DONALD VINH, microbiologiste-
infectiologue, McGill
- Les hospitalisations ne sont
pas idéales présentement. On a
beaucoup de personnes encore
dans les hôpitaux à travers
la province.
- Le Docteur Vinh émet
des doutes sur la t
du masque obligatoire.
Pour lui, la COVID l'a bien
démontré : difficile de prédire
le futur d'ici le 14 mai.- Toutc
ce virus! Jamais un scientifique
robuste prometterait quelque
chose dans l'avenir parce que
dans la médecine, et dans
la science, rien n'est garanti.
- La Santé publique va aussi
recommander aux plus vulnérables
de garder le masque. Mais tout
n'est pas encore décidé.
- Les RPA, c'est encore
ssion.
- Les gestionnaires de Résidence
privés pour aînés qui donnent
des soins souhaitent le maintien
du masque. Mais c'est une autre
histoire pour les RPA avec
des résidents autonomes.
MARC FORTIN, PDG, Regroupement
québécois, résidences pour aînés
- En vieillissant, veut, veut
pas, l'ouie descend un peu.
Les gens ont de la misère à se
comprendre avec le masque. Donc,
on préfèrait évidemment enlever
le masque pour les résidences
autonomes.
- Le port du masque est
obligatoire au Québec dans
les lieux publics depuis
le 18 juillet 2020.
C'est demain, à 11 he que
le Dr Boileau va annoncer
la fin de cette mesure phare
de la pandémie.
Ici Pierre-Alexandre Bolduc,
Radio-Canada, Québec.